hi guys I'm Erik Bosse and this is a
breakdown of The Walking Dead Season
eight episode 10 the Lost and the
plunderers a title taken from the sign
outside Alexandria Mercy for the lost
vengeance for the plunderers and yeah
apparently there is a God in this
Walking Dead universe because he
unleashed some pretty nasty vengeance on
those plundering scavengers forcing
jatis to shred them all up in a
mincemeat I'm gonna break down all the
big stuff from this episode details and
connections to past episodes that you
might have missed what this all means
and let's start with a big question
brought to us on Twitter by Jim what
will be the repercussions for Simon
after he went against negan and killed
the trash people and thank you Jim for
calling them what they deserve to be
called trash people yes let's talk about
Simon this episode ever since the
Savior's arrived Simon has been used as
a sort of negan surrogate another smiley
savage that the show would use whenever
MC didn't feel like paying Jeffrey Dean
Morgan for another episode but now we're
starting to see some major divisions
between the two characters by murdering
nearly a hundred people in the landfill
Simon is painting himself literally as a
more ruthless less trusting hardliner
Meagan has never been this bloodthirsty
his violence is more gesture-based kill
one the others fall in line but Simon
doesn't share his boss's optimism that
they can sustain this Empire in his eyes
rick has poisoned the well in these gen1
colonies and it's may be time to cut
losses branch out and find new colonies
and that interestingly positions negan
as the more diplomatic sympathetic
villain in his radio chat with Rick at
the end of the episode
negan made a lot of good points Rick did
put his responsibilities as a father on
the back burner while playing war games
and negan seemed genuinely sad over
Carl's death recognizing that the kid's
cleverness and pragmatism was something
they needed to survive in this world
while it may be a step too far to blame
Carl's death on either of these men Rick
is showing more immaturity here
unlike negan Rick isn't really truly
mourning his son he doesn't spend too
much time reflecting on Carl's final
words and notice how he doesn't even
read
letter to him he just reads negan's
letter looking for ways he can spin
Carl's words against his enemy so
looking at this whole half season from a
bird's eye view I think we're gonna
start seeing a more softer side to negan
a negan that we could imagine Rick
forming a truce with maybe even living
with a negan who maybe censors himself
for once holy crud with Simon taking
over negan's more sadistic villainous
tendencies and maybe taking those to the
next level so to return to the question
what repercussions will that create for
Simon well we got a hint that Simon
won't get away with slaughtering the
scavengers and lying about it to negan
not only was there yeah whole squad of
Savior foot soldiers who could just
easily rat him out there was a close-up
of his boots covered in that blue paint
from his messy scuffle with jatis that
could lead Simon to being caught two
blue booted when the truth comes out now
sure Rick also stepped in that blue
paint I could see negan left to play
judge to Cyprien whose boot is bluer but
ultimately I think Simon's new extremism
makes him not long for this world really
in order to achieve anything close to
Carl's vision of a peaceful aftermath
with Rick and negan on the same side the
war will have to end with the most
ruthless aspects of the Savior's which
now appears to be Simon to end and yeah
I could see negan executing his
right-hand man as a kind of gesture of
goodwill that would mean a lot to Rick
and his people now a lot of you guys
were asking what exactly Carl wrote in
his letter to negan and you could kind
of read it if you paused it at just the
right time so let's do that here in our
segment zoom and enhance okay let's take
a look at this letter I'm just gonna
read what I can see here negan this is
Carl yeah someone I got bit we didn't
even have a yachtie I was just helping
someone and now you gotta go you might
be gone maybe my dad killed you but I
don't think so I think you're working on
a way out maybe you got out maybe the
Lost Cause and you just want to kill all
of us I think you have to be who you are
is what you wanted I wanted to ask you
do
maybe you'll beat us if you do there'll
just be someone the way out is working
together it's forgiving and right as we
start to get to the meat of this at the
bottom there there's something about
offers you peace okay yeah so this is a
pretty clear plea from Carl extending of
the olive branch to negan trying to end
this war without too much fighting but
for me the biggest takeaway from this is
Rick's failure to take in Carl's message
he just sees this as a kid trying to
break up a fight between its dad and his
uncle negan father figure stop fighting
but Rick doesn't understand or care why
I think Rick learning this lesson will
be his primary motivator over these next
six episodes now this episode also
contains some interesting connections to
past episode so let's review those in
our segment callbacks the big one some
of you guys asked about came in line
Simon said to Shadis he asked her what's
the deal with the helipad in the back
the solar panels what was this place a
helipad this could be a callback to the
mysterious final shot of episode 5 this
season where Rick saw a helicopter
flying over his head remember he was on
his way to the landfill in that moment
so I think this means the owner that
helicopter was the scavengers Jadis
later tells Rick and Michonne that this
location was always a landfill just
flatter and it just didn't have the maze
of trash heaps until she settled it but
I think there's a greater mystery to
this society than we've realized we saw
Jadis pull a box of candy apple sauce
from a hidden compartment in the heap so
what else is being covered up what are
those solar panels generating power for
maybe it's just me but I'm thinking The
Walking Dead could be pulling a similar
move that lost did where the mysterious
others disguised themselves as trash
people when actually they lived in a
pretty cushy town with indoor plumbing
so I don't think the book is closed on
Jadis and the scavengers we'll see as
for a few other callbacks I noticed
Jadis had to deal with all of her former
soldiers now zombified and if you think
about it this parallels what Ezekiel had
to go through back in episode 4 both
community leaders pay the price of an
alliance with Rick grieving is all their
former friends turned into walkers
before their eyes and just like that
episode saw Ezekiel dropping his
Reagle act now we see Janus dropping her
heap sturb act where I guess sentences
don't need subjects at both cases they
cut I also like the callback with
Simon's interest in art he complements J
disses Picasso esque painting similar to
how he complimented and later stole that
Charles v painting from the hilltop in
season 7 Simon as an art thief kind of
casts him as a classic war plunderer
just kind of an interesting historical
perspective on him now I talked earlier
about the blue paint Jadis is using to
paint this painting and it's interesting
that it's the same color paint that Carl
and Judith used to make their handprints
on the front porch last episode which
Michonne found this episode almost like
this episode is using blue handprints
and footprints to track characters
whereabouts
we'll see if anything comes from that
there also definitely some parallel
moments and Maggie's sending the savior
Dean as a walker back to negan in this
crate now obviously this is intended to
echo Sasha whom negan returned to Rick
and his people but she committed suicide
inside and came out as a walker this is
another example of negan being really
less of a savage than team Rick makes
him out to be but leaders like Rick and
Maggie still reciprocate that savagery
back to him
this show is asking us really who the
true villains are but let's move on to
the cultural influences in this episode
in our segment - under the influence
really this episode had an interesting
structure segmented in chapters that
followed each character's journey
Jada's the story takes place earlier in
the chronology than Rick and Michonne
stories do catching us up to why the
blue paint was spilled and why the
scavengers had turned into walkers this
nonlinear structure is something we've
seen before like in movies the 1999
movie go it follows three intertwining
storylines resetting to the top of the
day as it moves on from story to story
this structure was later parodied in an
episode of The Simpsons you can also say
Quentin Tarantino used this device in
the movie Pulp Fiction but Pulp Fiction
is really more about telling three
different short stories within the same
world with some of the same characters
instead of telling one macro narrative
from multiple characters points of views
I wish this episode of The Walking Dead
to get more narrative tension or
surprise out of these overlapping arcs
the Wego or Pulp Fiction did but I'll
say the way that it set up the mystery
and later reveal of what went down with
the scavengers definitely made me more
interested in jatis than I've ever been
before really I think the point of
structuring the episode this way was to
connect to this episode's theme so let's
talk about the deeper meaning remember
this episode was titled the lost in the
plunderers referencing the sign outside
Alexandria which read mercy for the lost
vengeance for the plunderers now the
Assumption there is that there are only
two kinds of survivors left in this
world those who are lost and those who
plunder Rick and his people see
themselves as the loss to the
well-meaning Whoville survivors who saw
Alexandria in these new communities as a
refuge that they deserve they believed
themselves and other lost people deserve
mercy and then they see negan and the
other enemies as plunderers those who
invade and steal without rights they
deserve nothing but vengeance now the
irony of this assumption is that it
really goes both ways from Megan's point
of view he and his forces were once lost
and now they're saviors saving the world
from more chaos and negan's eyes rick is
the plunderer Rick invades he steals he
kills and that's not too far off even
when Rick arrived at Alexandra in season
5 remember he conspired to kill everyone
there and take over if he had to so I
think this episode deliberately
structures each chapter from a different
characters perspective to illustrate
this whole subjectivity negan isn't
necessarily the villain and Rick isn't
necessarily the hero we thought these
men were with a simple shift in
perspective the plunderers can be just
as lost and the loss can be just as
plunder Rory let's move on to this
week's kill count Wow Rick Michonne and
Jay dis proved to be very deadly when it
comes to taking out walkers this episode
yeah we got to give it to Simon who shot
the scavengers Brian and Tammy oh and
defied negan to order the deaths of 94
other scavengers - Jadis guys they were
slaughtered that makes this the single
deadliest episode of The Walking Dead
ever which really should have more of an
emotional effect on me but how much do
these trash people count anyway a
question for you guys if not negan who
is now The Walking Dead's deadliest
villain Simon Rick
Morgan Henry now that kids somehow had
the strength to jab a spear through a
living man's skull whose
several feet taller than him now yeah it
doesn't totally make sense which is why
this kid scares the crap out of me so
much like what else can he do comment
down below and let me know your thoughts
or tweet me directly at ei vas and
following the rockstars on Twitter add
for updates on our videos like this
video and subscribe to new rockstars for
a deep obsessive analysis of The Walking
Dead and yeah make sure to check out my
breakdowns of all the episodes this
season up until this point for all the
other stuff that you might have missed
and if you really want to help this
channel you can contribute any small
amount to us on patreon big thanks to
all of our donors especially Allen
Fleming thanks for watching guys bye